adepte de la grande toile bonjour
aujourd'hui nous allons parler de ce qui
risque probablement d'être le film de
l'année 2015
je veux bien sûr parler de mad max fury
road de george miller
sorti il y a quelques jours sur les
écrans du monde entier
si comme moi vous commencez légèrement à
saturer des suites ou des reboot de
vieilles franchises et que la volonté
des gros studios de saborder toute idée
nouvelle vous révolte alors mad max fury
road pose un petit problème c'est une
suite d'une saga vieille de 30 ans et a
priori le début d'une nouvelle franchise
comme on en voit naître à la lc temps ci
alors pourquoi se distingue-t-il du
reste avant de parler du film on va
revenir quelques mois en arrière
en novembre dernier les internautes
découvrent est quasiment simultanément
les bandes-annonces de jurassic world
terminator dinis mad max iv et star wars
épisode 7
vous vous êtes peut-être à mesurer à
compter le nombre de plans de la bande
annonce de jurassic world qui renvoie
très explicitement aux premiers jurassic
park
au point qu'on peut d'ores et déjà
prendre les paris pour savoir qui de
bryce dallas howard ou de chris pratt se
fera été relevé dessus par un
brachiosaure
du côté de terminator gino 6 c'est
carrément la fête du slip en plus de
jouer au docteur frankenstein avec le
premier épisode de james cameron hulu
rebalance les mêmes répliques qui tourne
en boucle depuis trois films et je suis
quasiment certain que le verbe revenir
sera à nouveau conjuguer à tous les
temps
je reviendrai je vais revenir je suis
revenue dans les deux cas quand on voit
enfin poindre l'ombre d'une idée à peu
près original à savoir des rapports
apprivoiser et à john connor méchant il
faut bien avouer que ça sent le gros
what the fuck des familles à deux doigts
de l'it et les bases mêmes de l'univers
mais bon si ça trouve ce sera bien quand
même un autre exemple l' ultra méga giga
attendu star wars épisode 7 qui joue
visiblement la même carte nostalgique
mais qui semble avoir droit à un régime
spécial de la part des geeks et ouais
quand l'apparition d'un vieux pâtit
décati qui a à peine eu le temps de
troquer sa chemise hawaïenne contre un
déguisement de han solo déclenché un
orgasme planétaire il ya de fortes
chances que le film donne très
exactement ce que les gens veulent ceux
qui ont rempli à peu près la même
fonction auprès des spectateurs qu'un
qu'un doudou pour un bébé c'est à dire
un objet transitionnel fait pour
rassurer bombay quelle différence avec
mad max fury road la différence la voilà
contrairement aux films précités l'idée
d'un nouveau mad max n'est pas née suite
à une réunion exécutif en quête de
vieilles licences a ressuscité et le
film n'a pas été confié aux mains d'un
yes man interchangeable avec un cahier
des charges gros comme ça respecte et
non elle date au moins de 2003 et elle
est attribué au seul george miller qui
al'avantage de cumulé depuis le début de
sa carrière
les casquettes de réalisateur scénariste
et producteur
un type qui a toujours pris soin de se
réinventer quand il aborde la notion de
suite offrant à chaque fois des oeuvres
très différente du film matriciel
rappelons qu'entre mad max 1 et mad max
3 on est passé de l'interdiction en
france pourquoi tu noteras violence au
film pourquoi il n'a également jamais eu
peur de décontenancer le public quitte à
risquer un bide sévère au box office
le trailer de mad max était le seul à ne
pas jouer la carte de la nostalgie
aucun renvoi explicite aux trois
épisodes ou qu'un caméo de mel gibson
le seul lien vraiment mise en avant avec
la trilogie c'est george miller
finalement malgré son statut de
quatrième épisode de grosse franchise
mad max semblait proposer quelque chose
de neuf et pas un album photo souvenir
cinéphile mais bon il ya des films de
merde avec des super bande annonce et
inversement
alors quel verdict pour ce fury road et
bien les promesses ne sont pas tenues
elles sont atomisés 80 dans un grand
fracas métallique
ce quatrième mad max est un trip de deux
heures sur la fury road où nos yeux nos
oreilles et notre cerveau sont emportés
dans un maelström nos sensations que
seul le cinéma le vrai celui qui ne
repose quasiment pas sur les dialogues
peut offrir et dire qu'un spectacle
aussi vivifiant et l'offre internet de
70 piges
nous n'allons pas nous lancer dans une
analyse du film car aussi détaillé soit
elle jamais elle ne rendra justice à
l'expérience de cinéma total que
représente ce film de malades
beaucoup de choses ont déjà été écrites
ici ou là sur fury road est étonnamment
assez peu de bêtises et dans la mesure
où le film semble rouler également sur
la route du succès public
on ne va pas jouer aux ardents
défenseurs envers et contre tout ce qui
nous intéresse en revanche si la place
atypique de ce blockbuster dans le
paysage cinématographique actuelle comme
le suggérait le trailer george miller ne
se complaît jamais dans la nostalgie ni
dans le fan service
il prend même un malin plaisir à
bousculer les fans de la trilogie
originelle allant chercher le méchant du
premier film pour lui faire jouer le
rôle d'un méchant complètement différent
ou trop quand le trauma du héros pour un
autre dont nous n'avions jamais entendu
parler jusque là il ya évidemment pas
mal de clin d'oeil aux épisodes
précédents le plan subliminal des yeux
exorbités le shotgun à canon scié la
boîte à musique
une fratrie composée d'un an et d'un
géant ou encore une cosmogonie fait de
bric et de broc mais aucun de ces clins
d'oeil n'est gratuit le but affiché de
miller et de retrouver la rage du
premier mad max l'univers désole t
violent du deuxième opus et la proche
mythologie du troisième film en fait
puisqu'on parle bagnole on peut dire
qu'ils récupèrent des pièces détachées
de ses précédents films pour
reconstruire un véhicule surpuissante
flambant neuf
personnellement je n'avais pas vu un
réalisateur revisitées ainsi sa
filmographie pour un extraire la
quintessence depuis le spider man de sam
raimi
d'ailleurs mad max fury road a tout à
fait sa place dans la filmographie de
george miller à la droite du dernier
chef-d'oeuvre en date du réalisateur
happy feet 2 en fait que ce soit avec
des barbares sanguinaires des cochons de
bergers des sorcières ou des pingouins
sur la banquise
george miller nous racontent plusieurs
aspects d'une seule et même histoire
celle de héros qui transcendent leur
condition au ramener l'harmonie dans un
monde discordants est aux mains de faux
prophètes et le changer à jamais